Film Courage: Once the screenwriter finishes
a script, what are they doing with it?
Carole Kirschner, Author: They are keeping
it in a drawer and they’re just waiting
for somebody to come along.
That’s what…no…
Film Courage: And they are Tweeting about
it.
Carole Kirschner: They are Tweeting about
it “I’ve got a great script.”
Well, what you want to do is you want to get
it out into the world absolutely and there
is a couple of ways to do that.
One is to send it to somebody, to give it
to somebody who can give it to somebody somebody
else, who can give it to somebody who is in
a position to evaluate it or possibly hire
you or represent you.
I’ve told this story many times about Madonna’s
manicurist.
She goes on the road with Madonna but when
she wasn’t on the road, she had a salon,
she worked at a salon and there was a woman
who came in and was her customer (her regular
customer) and this woman had a son who was
a screenwriter and she would tell the manicurist
“My son!
He’s so talented.”
And then one day she said “Would you show
his script to Madonna?”
And no…”Would you read his script?”
And the manicurist said “Sure.”
Everybody thinks they know how to read a script.
So she read it and said “You know what?
This is really good.”
And so the mom said “Would you show it to
Madonna?”
And the manicurist said “Yeah…”
Now the manicurist never gave it to Madonna,
she gave it to Madonna’s assistant.
But the assistant read it and thought it was
good and then she actually handed it to Madonna.
Madonna eventually (this whole thing took
like a year), she read it, she thought it
was good and she gave it to her agent and
the agent thought it was good, brought the
guy in and he got representation.
So you never know.
You know, a friend of a friend of a friend
(somebody who can get it to a junior agent,
a junior manager, a junior executive).
Or get it higher up if you know somebody who
knows somebody, so you want to launch it into
the world.
You also want to absolutely enter it into
contests but don’t spend your money on Shmegeggie
screenplay contests, only do the top five
or six prestigious ones because the truth
is the community is not looking at the (I
don’t mean to insult anybody) certain screenplay
writing contest (most likely they’re not).
Film Courage: How would you know?
Is there a site or how would you know what
are the top contests?
Carole Kirschner: Yeah, Google ‘Top Screenwriting
Contests.’
You know, it’s certainly going to be Nichol’s,
it’s going to be Page [The Page Awards],
it’s going to be Austin [Austin Film Festival],
there’s Final Draft, there’s others.
Definitely go online and just Google ‘Top’
ones.
There’s lots of sites that talk about the
best ones.
The ones I just mentioned are well-known and
well-received.
In television there’s The Tracking-Board,
which is really good.
That’s the thing that Mickey Fisher entered
his on Tracking B [The Tracking-Board].
Film Courage: Interesting.
And that’s the name of the site, The Tracking-Board?
Carole Kirschner: Yes.